- This video is brought to you by keeps.
(upbeat music)
What's up, everybody.
My name is Michael Burns,
and today for the first time ever,
I'm gonna open up about my greatest fear.
- Disney.
- I'm absolutely terrified
of Disney adults.
Let me explain.
A couple years back,
we casually discussed
the phenomenon of adults
who are super enthusiastic about Disney
on our podcast Culture Binge,
and I shared some tongue in cheek thoughts
about the unaccompanied
old to Disney World.
I get a little judgey
when I see like legit
adults get hella emotional
about going to a kid's park.
If I was a parent, let's say,
and I'm taking my kids to Disney,
and we had to wait to get on a ride
'cause a bunch of (beep) 37 year olds
are all like getting emotional
to get on the tea cups or whatever.
I'm just a little pissed.
Maybe get out of the way right now
or go to like, I don't know, the zone
where they have like alcoholic
beverages and churros
and just chill there while
the kids go on the rides.
Now I moved on with my life,
but a few days later,
a Disney YouTuber posted
an entire reaction video
that took umbrage with my comments.
- I started to watch it,
and it deeply disturbed me.
- And ever since, I get regular
DMs from dummy accounts,
threatening my life or making fun of me
or implying that I hate anyone
who didn't have a great childhood.
And while sometimes annoying,
this experience has mostly
left me wondering why.
And this fiery reaction
to very same criticism
has led the team at Wisecrack
to investigating an important question
are Disney adults kind of a cult,
or put more nicely,
are they inadvertently
practicing their own religion?
And if so, can their zealotry
tell us anything interesting
about modern society at large?
Let's find out in this Wisecrack
edition on Disney Adults,
is Disney a religion part one.
Oh, and if you decide to make
a reaction video to this one,
just tag us in it.
And before we get into it,
just a quick note while
researching this topic,
we found way more interesting stuff
than could possibly fit
into just one video.
So we're splitting this
one into a two-parter.
Sort of like a godfather
godfather part two situation,
except I'm not gonna kill
my own brother in part two.
- I know it was you, Fredo.
- This video is going to cover
some recent Disney adult drama
and then contextualize what
we actually mean when we ask
if Disney is a religion.
Then in part two,
we'll look at the
intricacies of how Disney
maybe functions as a religion.
And don't worry, unlike
Francis Ford Coppola,
we know when to end something
great after two parts.
- My lucky coat.
- But before we get into it,
I wanna tell you about
this video sponsor, Keeps.
Keeps is a prescription service
that helps guys prevent hair loss.
It's convenient, affordable, and relevant
to a lot of people out there
because two outta three men
experience some form of
male pattern baldness
by the time they're 35.
The process begins with
a free consultation
with a license Keeps doctor
who will recommend the
FDA approved prescriptions
and over the counter medications
that best fit your needs.
These hair loss prevention medications
will automatically land at
your door every three months.
So you don't have to bother
with ordering refills.
As your treatment plan goes on,
you can message or keeps doctor 24/7
to update them on your progress
and to ask any questions you may have.
Now, it typically takes
between four and six months
to start seeing results,
so get started today to
hang onto the hair you have.
If you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss,
go to keeps.com/wisecrack
or click the link in the description
to receive 50% off your first order.
That's keeps.com/wisecrack.
Now back to the show.
Now for a little bit of story time
starring ye olde internet.
last month, Reddit's amitheasshole forum
bot-lighted a recently married couple
who invited their nearest and dearest
to a lavish Disney World wedding,
where they allegedly
instructed their guests
to buy their own food at nearby facilities
or vending machines.
Yeah, they expected guests
to purchase their own food
at a wedding reception.
Why so stingy?
Oh, just because the happy couple
had decided to spend their
entire food budget on appearances
by official Minnie and Mickey
Mouse costumed cast members.
As many were quick to point out,
weddings at Disney come with
a minimum catering budget,
so it's likely the story was
fabricated or exaggerated.
But it nonetheless struck a
nerve with the Twitter-verse
because if there's one place
the internet loves to
aim its collective ire,
it's at the Disney extended universe's
enthusiastic adult acolytes.
From Disney bounders who go to the park
in outfits inspired by
their favorite characters
to rich TikTokers moving
into a gated community
of Disney world mansions,
the folks at karaoke night
who bring the mood down
with a passionate rendition
of "God Helped the Outcast
from the Hunchback of Notre Dame."
♪ God ♪
Enthusiasm for Disney
just seems to rub the
general public the wrong way,
and to be fair and balanced,
I confess to once singing this song
"I'll Make a Man Out of You
from the movie Mulan"
at a karaoke bar in Northfield, Minnesota.
I think it was the summer of 2009,
and to all who were in attendance,
I formally apologize.
So the backlash over this
food less Disney wedding
eventually spurred professor
of religious studies
Dr. Jodi Eichler-Levine to
bravely step into the discourse.
She urged the very online folks
to have a little compassion
for Disney adults. Why?
Because according to Eichler-Levine,
Disney adulting is akin
to practicing a religion,
and we ought to be a little more sensitive
to people's sacred experiences
at the church of Mickey Mouse.
In the name of the Minnie,
Mickey, and Donald Duck. Amen.
Don't put that in the video.
In her sympathetic Twitter
thread, she writes,
if we measure religion
not by its truth-claims
but by its power in people's lives,
then Disney is as much
a religion as anything.
It is, at the very least,
a sight of meaning and human fellowship,
even if you hate it.
She argues that people embrace Disney
for various personal reasons.
Maybe Disney World was the only place
where your parents ever seemed happy.
Maybe you watched frozen
on your first date
with your spouse,
or maybe you found solace
dumping your favorite uncle's
ashes on Splash Mountain.
Please don't try the last one.
It's very much illegal.
But this argument caused many to wonder.
Was Eichler Levine defending Disney adults
or offering an unflattering diagnosis
of their spiritual condition?
And does Disney fandom really
have that much in common
with religious worship?
Let's take a step back
and start by approaching
Disney adults as a fandom.
Scholar Cornel Sandvoss
writes that fandom is defined
by the regular emotionally
involved consumption
of a given popular narrative or text.
So Disney lovers who have cried
over Mufasa's death 3000 times
certainly would seem to fit the bill.
Now, the link between fandom and religion
has long been discussed
in academic circles.
In fact, the word fan even
has religious etymology
coming from the Latin word fanaticus,
which meant attendant of the temple
or the fanus or fanus,
fan of, I'll say it, fan of the
anus is what it sounds like,
and that's fine.
And, of course,
deeply religious people
are often called fanatics.
It's also the name
of the Philadelphia Phillie's
very chaotic looking mascot.
As scholar Vernon Chadwick argues,
the Latin root of religion, religio,
is defined not in terms
of the truth of dogma
but the strength of communal
bonds forms by shared belief.
Such a community can manifest
around shared rights of worship
or sacred objects or sites.
Chadwick explains that taking care of
and maintaining these
elements of a religion
easily become ends in themselves,
independent of explicitly defined
and defended articles of belief.
This is all to say
religion could be viewed
less as what you believe
and more as what you do,
and this makes sense as
many organized religions
place a big emphasis on religion
being about acts of
service and lived virtues.
Friend of the channel
soaring character guard
also help this view calling
Christianity a practice
rather than just being a system
of like bullet pointed beliefs.
And folks have long been squeaked out
by what intense fans
do in their communities
specifically because of
the seeming proximity
to religious experience.
For example, when Elvis's gyrating hips
made children fall into tearful hysterics,
some parents got real nervous
because huge emotional reactions
were ideally meant for church revivals,
not sexual awakenings
via the Ed Sullivan Show.
Christian groups even worried
that Christian contemporary music
would distract its fans
from worshiping God
and lead them towards secularism.
Instead it just made millions
and millions of dollars
and produce gems like this.
♪ If you do drugs and
you think you're cool, ♪
you need to come to sunday school.
What's more, the
conventional language we use
to talk about fandom
certainly invokes religion.
We call niche fandoms, cults,
and talk about our culture
of celebrity worship.
So it's no wonder scholars of religion,
media, and fandom alike
have grappled for decades
with the question,
do fandoms constitute a religion?
A scholar Mark Duffett put
it because fan phenomena
can sometimes look similar to
moments of religious ecstasy,
the idea that fandom is like a religion
is a ready-made metaphor.
I also like the notion
of religious ecstasy,
like going to church on ecstasy,
that sounds fun.
Don't do it, but do it.
Duffett notes that some
academic researchers
who subscribe to this
interpretation of fandom
treated fans with empathy
while others use the analogy
to stereotype and lambaste
fans as servile and misguided;
that is to say to treat
fandom as a religious practice
sometimes means to pathologize the fan.
IE to regard or treat them
as psychologically abnormal or unhealthy.
It's worth noting that
some forms of fandom
are basically treated as
normal by our society,
while others are viewed with skepticism.
Nobody's gonna call you a cultist
for wearing your Tom
Brady Jersey for a week
leading up to the super bowl,
but if you carry around your
replica of Thor's hammer
for a week leading up
to the new MCU movie,
people will probably have thoughts.
And we certainly see
plenty of pathologizing
when it comes to Disney adults,
especially on the internet.
Articles that titles like,
Disney adults are the most
terrifying people on the planet,
and they need to be
stopped, regularly pop up.
With assertions that Disney adults pension
for getting off on nostalgia
is worse than being an
actual serial killer.
Though, come to think of it,
a serial killer who is also a Disney adult
would be the most nightmarish
thing I could ever imagine.
But snarky Twitter users
didn't invent this kind
of cultural pathologizing.
Many early scholars of then
burgeoning mass culture
approached early fans much the same way,
specifically a Marxist powerhouse
of German intellectuals
who formed what's called
the Frankfurt school,
sort of like the goof troupe
of cranky philosophers.
Members included dudes
like Theodor Adorno,
Walter Benjamin, and Max Wertheimer,
who collectively pioneered the discipline
we now know as critical theory.
Critical theory views philosophy
and social theory's primary purposes
as being tools to critique social
and political structures of power,
and when several of these folks
fled Nazi Germany for America,
they found plenty to
critique about its culture.
Writing for Vox,
Sean Illing explains,
they saw the yolk of capitalist ideology
wherever they looked in films, in radio,
in popular music, in literature,
Adorno called this the culture industry,
and Illing notes,
he cautioned that it
blurred the distinction
between truth and fiction
between the commercial and the political.
As journalists and authors
Stuart Jeffries explains,
these scholars wondered
why a socialist revolution
had swept across Russia
while failing to manifest in
advanced industrialized nations
like Germany and the United States.
He writes, "they concluded that culture
and the use of the media
was the primary tool
for oppressing the masses
without the masses realizing
that they're being oppressed."
And so the argument went mass
culture with its flashy lights
and captivating narratives
was indoctrinating people
into dominant ideologies.
IE ways of thinking
that wouldn't threaten or upset
those in physicians of
economic and political power.
The culture industry thus caused people
to unconsciously and
unquestioningly accept
what the people in power
wanted them to believe.
In this way, these scholars thought
that culture was essentially
taking the place of
and functioning like
an organized religion.
Note that during this time,
religion was undergoing a decline in power
over the national psyche.
As Adorno and Wertheimer wrote,
"the sociological theory
that the loss of the support
of objectively established religion
has led to cultural chaos
is disproved every day;
for culture now impresses the
same stamp on everything."
That is to say culture
was indoctrinating people
into the sorts of dominant ideologies,
which were once exclusively
the terrain of religion.
This development upset
these guys to no end,
and Adorno even pen a hateful paper
about the insidious national
disease of jazz music,
like who doesn't like jazz music.
It's it's really nice.
What's interesting though is,
is who made jazz music at that time?
(trumpet blaring)
So God only knows
what he would think of
contemporary Disney culture
with all its mouse ears, season passes,
and Disney-themed funeral companies.
Oh, and we're not making that last one up,
if I ever die and you
(beep) dare to bury me
in Mickey Mouse ears,
I'm gonna come back as a
hybrid zombie and ghost,
and just haunt the (beep) outta you.
Anyway, going forward,
scholars wouldn't all share
Adorno's scorn for mass culture.
In the sixties,
England's Birmingham
School of Cultural Studies
started to take fans,
especially working class
ones, more seriously.
And in the eighties and nineties,
fandom scholarship really took a turn away
from those old unflattering portraits.
That's thanks largely
to the work of academics
like Henry Jenkins, who were also fans.
These acafans were already immersed
in the fandom cultures they were studying
and were thus more sympathetic.
Instead of diagnosing fans as docile
and semi brainwashed from afar,
these scholars asked fans
how and why they interacted
with their chosen media texts.
Also, I would like to announce
that I'm officially now an acafan
of the television shows, "Scrubs."
- Okay, Sasha, let's see
what your new engine can do.
(motor engine roaring)
- They asserted that fans
weren't uncritically absorbing ideologies
in mass media and blindly
adhering to the status quo.
Rather, they saw the way fans
would poach ideas and
characters and stories
from the things they liked.
They would then remake and remix them
to align with their own values,
often to tell us subversive
countercultural stories.
If you lived through Tumblr in the 2010,
you've seen enough Dustin
O and Kirken Splunk Splash
to know exactly what they mean,
even if I have no (beep)
idea what I just said.
- I love you.
- This poaching can also be seen
in some activities of Disney adults.
Take Garrett Smith and Jason Bitner,
who dressed as Woody and Buzz
for their elaborate toy
story themed wedding
remaking Disney cannon
to fit their love story.
I can only hope it was officiated
by a friend in a Mr. Potato head outfit.
This wave of scholars took
a utopian view of fandom,
and it felt it was
important not to see fans
as cultish or worshipful
but as enthusiastic
thoughtful consumers of media.
- A lot of us appreciate the fact
that it presents a very
positive view of the future.
It doesn't show the earth
being devastated by wars.
It shows us having finally figured out
how to solve our worst problems.
- That's because these scholars and fans
saw religiosity as
equivalent to irrationality
and painted religion
as an unfounded belief
in something supernatural
and ultimately not real.
And Henry Jenkins's phrasing
calling fans religious paints them
as prone to false beliefs,
orgiastic excess, possession, and madness.
And clearly, he's talking
about Disney character
cosplay orgys there,
and I would like to see it.
Labeling fans as religious
fanatics, he said,
can also be inherently
othering and stigmatizing.
It makes them out to be obsessive devotees
who look at Captain
Kirk as a literal deity
and pray to Obi-Wan Kenobi for wisdom.
These scholars tried to distance
fan culture from religion
and define fans
as rational autonomous
media consumers and critics.
As Jenkins puts it,
"as a religion you bring back
in this notion of literal belief,
and it implies that fans are
unable to separate fiction
from reality or that they
supposedly act on the text
as if it were literally true."
However, this, according
to many religious scholars,
is a problematic view of religion.
For one, it paints
religious people as childish
or rational and disconnected
from the real world.
It asserts that they
don't question their text
and take them as absolute truth.
What's more, it maps Western
conceptions of religion,
specifically Christianity,
onto hugely diverse cultural traditions
that may bear little to
no resemblance to it.
Not all religious movements
require literal beliefs
in the supernatural or deities.
Not all religions make grand truth-claims
or passing a metaphysical realm,
or even have a cohesive set of traditions.
Scholars Carole M. Cusack
and Venetia Laura Delano
Robertson explains,
"religion is today studied
as not exclusively a tradition-based
or faith-based practice,
but a rationale, an experience.
So when scholars of religion
compare the experiences of Disney adults
to those of religious adherence,
they're not asserting that a
Disney filed drinking water
from each of the parks
fountains believes themself
to be consuming the literal
trans substantiated blood
of his lord and savior Donald Duck
nor do they mean that
someone brought to tears
by a fireworks display
truly believes themselves to
be witnessing fairy magic.
Instead they see Disney lovers
as participating in a secularized version
of religious fervor
in which they encounter a deeply personal
and experiential connection
to something bigger than themselves.
So clearly, there's been
some scholarly disagreement.
Some justify viewing
fandoms embrasive culture
as a kind of replacement for religion,
others think that fans are
doing something very different.
So with scholars disagreeing
on the question of whether or not Disney
can properly be considered a religion,
we think the best way to get
to the bottom of this question
is to step back and
reconsider the question,
what makes a religion anyway,
and then we can see how
much overlap there is
between organized religion
as it's commonly practiced
and the habits and practices
of the Disney adult community.
One thing that's for sure
is that there's no organized religion
that says it's cool to
leave menacing comments
on the wedding photos of
a gentle YouTube post,
but we'll get to all that in part two,
where we'll also be asking,
is there anything that Disney adults
can tell us about contemporary society
other than that the most
important thing you can do
when planning a wedding
is keep your guest well fed
and with fresh drinks in hand.
So check back later this
week to watch us try
and answer all those
questions once and for all,
assuming, of course, that a
gang of irate Disney adults
don't kidnap me first.
So if you see me blink
twice in the next video,
I'm in trouble, call for help.
In the meantime,
let us know your thoughts
on the church of Walt
in the comments.
A big thanks to our Patreons
for all your support,
and be sure to check out
our revamped Patreon page.
Show off your fandom by giving
this video the old thumbs up,
hit that subscribe button
like you're pulling down the
safety bar on space mountain,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
As always thanks for watching,
and be sure to check out part two.
(upbeat music)